And I will resist the urge to try to organize a meetup during your wedding. I mean, we can definitely record a podcast while we're down there for sure. I mean, that's just, why would we not do that? I would say that I definitely think you and I are going to be talking a lot less about C++ and a lot more about other languages over the course of this year. Welcome to ADSB the podcast episode 221 recorded on January 22nd, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we make our 2025 predictions and chat about a plethora of other random topics. And then we're going to get some 2025 hot takes.
我会克制住想在你婚礼期间组织聚会的冲动。我的意思是，我们肯定可以在那儿录一期播客。我是说，这简直是，我们为什么不这么做呢？我想说，我绝对认为你和我今年会少谈很多 C++，而会更多地谈论其他语言。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 221 期，录制于 2025 年 1 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，我们将做出 2025 年的预测，并聊聊其他各种随机话题。然后我们还会分享一些 2025 年的热门观点。
I mean, technically the time this comes out, it's gonna be like mid February, but but it is January when recording this folks. So we're gonna get some. Will it be as good as the Empire Strikes Back, which was the prediction of like, I don't know, 2023. That was I mean, I like to put a what do you call it? A teaser episode or like a featured episode I think is what it's called and
我的意思是，严格来说，这期节目发布的时候大概是二月中旬，但各位，录制的时候还是在一月。所以我们会分享一些。它会像《帝国反击战》那样好吗？那可是 2023 年的预测，我不知道。我的意思是，我喜欢放一个，怎么说呢？一个预告片，或者叫特色剧集，我想是这么叫的，然后
I think that was episode one 50 no episode 150 was Is C++ dead? Which actually it might have been let's quickly go check because I actually I put the Star Wars music Disney hasn't come after me yet. Let's quickly go check because I actually I put the Star Wars music. Disney hasn't come after me yet. Let's see if we. Yeah, that was the one where we we we subpotted Oxide and Friends, but I think the the Star Wars one.
我想那是第 150 期，不，第 150 期是“C++ 死了吗？”。其实可能就是那期，让我们快速去查一下，因为我确实放了《星球大战》的音乐，迪士尼还没来找我麻烦。让我们快速去查一下，因为我确实放了《星球大战》的音乐。迪士尼还没来找我麻烦。让我们看看我们是否。是的，那期我们采访了 Oxide and Friends，但我认为《星球大战》那期。
Let's see. I think I put it in the title Star. Oh, yeah. Episode one eleven. Yeah, episode one eleven. When was this? January 6th of 2023. And I put the Star Wars music. I replaced our little jingle with the, I can't remember, it wasn't the Imperial March.
让我看看。我想我把它放在标题里了，Star。哦，是的。第 111 期。是的，第 111 期。那是什么时候？2023 年 1 月 6 日。我放了《星球大战》的音乐。我把我们的小片头曲换成了，我不记得了，不是《帝国进行曲》。
It was just the opening theme. That was, that was, did it come to fruition? I guess we've never done a retro on whether our predictions came true or not. There's a funny C++ committee story that I'm not 100% sure if I should tell, so I'll go ahead and tell it. a former chair of a subgroup who upon the first meeting where he came back to his subgroup after he retired his chair when he entered the room he had playing on his phone the Imperial March. It was just perfect.
只是开场主题曲。那是，那是，它实现了吗？我想我们从来没有回顾过我们的预测是否成真。有一个关于 C++ 委员会的有趣故事，我不确定是否应该讲，但我还是讲了吧。一位小组的前任主席，在他退休后第一次回到小组参加会议时，当他走进房间，他的手机里正播放着《帝国进行曲》。简直太完美了。
I know someone, my former boss walked down the wedding aisle to the Imperial March Oh, that's a great idea. That's a great. What are you gonna walk down the wedding the wedding aisle to? Uh, I haven't thought that far to be honest. I don't know some classic wedding music I don't know. It's up to Shima whatever she she wants. I'm not too particular about the music that I walk down the aisle to. I mean we're gonna be on the beach looking out at the ocean. So I guess maybe my back will be to the ocean. Everyone else will be looking out at the ocean. Yeah, because you want the good pictures. You want the good pictures. You're not gonna get to see the ocean. No ocean for you. Yeah, yeah. Anyways, we'll get to 2025 predictions and hot takes from Bryce in a moment. What was the meetup thing you were gonna mention?
我认识一个人，我以前的老板是伴随着《帝国进行曲》走进婚礼殿堂的。哦，那是个好主意。那是个好主意。你打算伴随着什么音乐走进婚礼殿堂？呃，老实说，我还没想那么远。我不知道，一些经典的婚礼音乐吧，我不知道。这取决于 Shima，她想要什么都行。对于我走进婚礼殿堂的音乐，我并不太挑剔。我的意思是，我们会在海滩上，面朝大海。所以我猜也许我会背对着大海。其他人会面朝大海。是的，因为你想要好的照片。你想要好的照片。你将看不到大海。没你的份了。是的，是的。总之，我们稍后会谈到 Bryce 对 2025 年的预测和热门观点。你要提到的聚会是什么？
So, I'm planning some meetups or, let me put it this way. I got some travel coming up this year and my new philosophy is that when I travel, I'm going to try to find meetups to speak at because why not? I'll give a brief list of some of the places that I'm going to, some of which I've already got meetups set up in, some of which I'm looking for people who might be interested in helping me arrange a meetup. So in February, I'm going to be in Paris and I've reached out to some of the C++ meetup people in Paris, still waiting to hear back and get something set up there. When in February? It's gonna be... I'm sorry,
所以，我正在计划一些聚会，或者，换个说法。我今年有一些旅行计划，我的新理念是，当我旅行时，我会尝试寻找可以演讲的聚会，因为为什么不呢？我会简要列出我要去的一些地方，其中一些我已经安排好了聚会，另一些我正在寻找可能愿意帮我安排聚会的人。所以二月份，我会去巴黎，我已经联系了一些巴黎的 C++ 聚会组织者，还在等待回复并安排在那里的活动。二月份什么时候？会是……抱歉，
it's not February. I am wrong about that. That's gonna be in March. In February I'm gonna be in Budapest and not announced yet but plan is I'm going to speak at the Budapest C++ meetup. We're thinking it's going to be... Oh no, it logged me out of Tripit, but I can go to just my calendar. It looks like it would be February 17th. Wow, so this might come out three days before February 17th. So if you are in Budapest probably not enough time to book a flight and fly there But if you're in the area, yeah, and then and then in March
不是二月。我搞错了。那是在三月。二月份我会去布达佩斯，虽然还没宣布，但计划是在布达佩斯 C++ 聚会上演讲。我们认为会是……哦不，Tripit 把我登出了，但我可以直接看我的日历。看起来应该是 2 月 17 日。哇，所以这期节目发布时可能离 2 月 17 日只有三天了。所以如果你在布达佩斯，可能没有足够的时间订机票飞过去。但如果你在附近，是的，然后，然后三月份
End of March I'm gonna be in Paris and trying to set up something with the local Paris C++ meetup. And then in April, no sorry, not April. I think it's the last day of March. I think March 31st, I'm going to be in London and I'm going to be speaking at the London C++ meetup. And then hopefully sometime in New York, sometime in May, we're going to set up something in New York. And then in June, I'll be in Hamburg, and we're hopefully going to organize something.
三月底我会去巴黎，并尝试与当地的巴黎 C++ 聚会组织一些活动。然后四月，不抱歉，不是四月。我想是三月的最后一天。我想 3 月 31 日，我会去伦敦，并将在伦敦 C++ 聚会上演讲。然后希望五月份在纽约的某个时候，我们能在纽约安排一些活动。然后在六月，我会去汉堡，我们希望组织一些活动。
That actually may be a bigger meetup with some other people from Nvidia. And then also I'll be in Sofia for the C++ committee meeting. And I'm not sure if they're going to organize a conference around then, but they did when they did the last C++ committee meeting in Bulgaria, and it was a great little event. I think just me and Bjarne were speakers, but it was a great little event. I think just me and
那可能是一个更大的聚会，会有其他来自 Nvidia 的人参加。然后我还会去索非亚参加 C++ 委员会会议。我不确定他们是否会围绕那个时间组织会议，但他们上次在保加利亚举行 C++ 委员会会议时确实组织了，那是一个很棒的小型活动。我想只有我和 Bjarne 是演讲者，但那是一个很棒的小型活动。我想只有我和
Bjarne were speakers but it was really well organized and hopeful they're gonna do something else there. So I'm gonna reach out to them see if they got something planned. And then the big exciting one is that in August we are going to meet my girlfriend and I are going to to East Africa. We are going to meet, my girlfriend and I are going to East Africa. We are going to Kenya, Ethiopia, and we'll briefly be in Tanzania in Zanzibar. And I'm trying to get connected with some folks to organize meetups in Kenya and Ethiopia. And I've been in contact with some folks in Kenya. Looks like that is underway.
Bjarne 是演讲者，但组织得非常好，希望他们能在那里再做点什么。所以我打算联系他们，看看他们是否有计划。然后最令人兴奋的是，八月份我们要去，我和我女朋友要去东非。我们要去，我和我女朋友要去东非。我们要去肯尼亚、埃塞俄比亚，还会短暂地去坦桑尼亚的桑给巴尔。我正在尝试联系一些人，在肯尼亚和埃塞俄比亚组织聚会。我已经和肯尼亚的一些人联系过了。看起来进展顺利。
But I have not been able to reach anyone in Ethiopia. So if you are in Ethiopia and you do tech things, C++ things, CUDA things, GPU things, and you're interested in helping to set up a meetup or you know some local tech meetups where I could give a talk at, please reach out to me. And I will resist the urge to try to organize a meetup during your wedding.
但我还没能联系到埃塞俄比亚的任何人。所以如果你在埃塞俄比亚，并且从事技术工作、C++ 工作、CUDA 工作、GPU 工作，并且有兴趣帮忙安排聚会，或者你知道我可以去演讲的当地技术聚会，请联系我。我会克制住想在你婚礼期间组织聚会的冲动。
I mean, we can definitely record a podcast while we're down there for sure. I mean, that's just, podcast while we're down there for sure. I mean that's just You know why would we not do that? I'm gonna I'm gonna check with Shima on that before before we Know I know know don't you don't you don't you think you're gonna be like don't you think you're gonna be like? Super bit well I guess the thing is like you picked like a good Size for your wedding because
我的意思是，我们肯定可以在那儿录一期播客。我的意思是，那只是，在那儿录播客肯定没问题。我的意思是，那只是，你知道为什么我们不这么做呢？在做决定之前，我会和 Shima 确认一下。不，我知道，别，别，别，你不觉得你会，你不觉得你会吗？超级忙，好吧，我想重点是，你为你的婚礼选了一个很好的规模，因为
I feel like if you have a wedding where you have like 200 guests, like you're not going to see everybody at your wedding and if you do, you're going to get to spend like two minutes with each person. And so like you said you had like what, like less than 100 people or something? At the moment, yeah. If I go to our RSVP websites, which I haven't checked in a while to be honest, it currently says that 70 people are going. But that's not the full number.
我觉得如果你举办一场有 200 位客人的婚礼，你不可能见到婚礼上的每一个人，如果你真的去见，你每人只能花两分钟。所以就像你说的，你有，什么，不到 100 人还是什么的？目前是这样，是的。如果我去我们的 RSVP 网站，老实说我有一段时间没看了，目前显示有 70 人参加。但那不是全部人数。
This is where like, what is it, 10 months away? And also too, I'm trying to figure out the stats is not I went to, oh, I see we're on I'm on the wrong. I'm on I got too many podcasts. I tried to go check, because there's, in the stats section of ADSP's hosting site, shout out to, yeah, should we plug this site? And now, well, reach out to them.
这是，什么，还有 10 个月？而且，我还在试图弄清楚统计数据，不是，我去，哦，我明白了，我是在，我是在错误的。我有太多的播客了。我试着去查一下，因为在 ADSP 托管网站的统计部分，向他们致敬，是的，我们要给这个网站打广告吗？现在，好吧，联系他们。
Maybe they can start, I paid this company too much money, because I got too many podcasts, and they charged me for each one. Maybe we should we should We should reach out and say hey, can I have my money back? If we mention you like once every couple podcasts or not money back Can we just like not pay money going forward man this website is so slow though? It's like taking like since I started talking to load the stats all right here. We go we go to locations and Just in the last five episodes,
也许他们可以开始，我付给这家公司太多钱了，因为我有太多的播客，他们每个都向我收费。也许我们应该，我们应该联系他们说，嘿，能把钱退给我吗？如果我们每隔几期播客提到你们一次，不是退钱，我们能不能以后就不用付钱了？伙计，这个网站太慢了。就像我开始说话以来，加载统计数据花了这么久。好了，我们去地点，就在过去五期节目里，
we've had 186 downloads from Africa. If we go, I guess we'll just stick with that. We'll stick with that. What are the African countries? One you were just in, Morocco, Kenya, Algeria. I have to eyeball this, Rwanda, that's already we're down to four and Ethiopia is not on that list. I gotta say, Morocco would be an excellent place to host a C++ conference or meetup
我们有 186 次来自非洲的下载。如果我们去，我想我们就坚持这个吧。我们就坚持这个。非洲国家有哪些？你刚去过的，摩洛哥、肯尼亚、阿尔及利亚。我得目测一下，卢旺达，我们已经降到四个了，埃塞俄比亚不在那个名单上。我得说，摩洛哥会是一个举办 C++ 会议或聚会的绝佳地点，
because it's very easy to get to Morocco from the east coast of the United States. It's easy to get there from Europe. It's a beautiful country, great food, very friendly people. We had an excellent time. It's pretty accessible to North Africa and parts of Central Africa. Yeah. And Zimbabwe was the last one. So now, that's only the last five episodes. I just hit all episodes, which I now, I assume is just gonna cause their server to fall over.
因为从美国东海岸去摩洛哥非常容易。从欧洲去那里也很容易。这是一个美丽的国家，食物很棒，人民非常友好。我们度过了一段美好的时光。它对北非和部分中非来说相当便利。是的。津巴布韦是最后一个。所以现在，那只是过去五期节目的数据。我刚刚点击了所有节目，现在，我假设这只会导致他们的服务器崩溃。
Because getting the stats on the last five took like 10 seconds. And I will let you know how many, or actually, wait, I said last five episodes, and then it said 186 downloads, and then I proceeded to say that the five episodes led to it only being five countries. So I don't know why that is how my logic worked. I should just search for the word.
因为获取过去五期的统计数据花了大约 10 秒钟。我会让你知道有多少，或者，等等，我说的是过去五期节目，然后显示 186 次下载，然后我接着说这五期节目只涉及五个国家。所以我不知道我的逻辑是怎么运作的。我应该直接搜索这个词。
I searched for ETH. Here's a little fun game. Only one country came up and it was the 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7th country on the list of rankings of countries that had downloads. Can you name the country that has the substring ETH in it, that is number seven on our list. What a fun game, folks. Play along, listener. And I'll give a hint if you can't come up with it in the next little bit. Give me a second here. Give me a second here.
我搜索了 ETH。这是一个有趣的小游戏。只有一个国家出现了，它是下载量排名列表中的第 1、2、3、4、5、6、7 个国家。你能说出那个包含子字符串 ETH 的国家吗，它是我们列表中的第七名。真是个有趣的游戏，伙计们。听众朋友们，一起玩吧。如果你一会儿想不出来，我会给个提示。给我一秒钟。给我一秒钟。
I think I just gotta think about this. You better not be going to an LLM. I hope you're just going to Google Maps. No. I guess it would be probably the Netherlands. Woo, you got it folks, he got it. That was fun, that was fun. That was a good one.
我想我得考虑一下。你最好别去用大语言模型。我希望你只是在用谷歌地图。不。我想那可能是荷兰。呜，你猜对了，伙计们，他猜对了。那很有趣，那很有趣。那是个好问题。
I didn't think, that's hard to think of. I'm not sure I would have gotten that. I mean, there can't be that many with ETH in there, right? The stats have loaded. When I said I was gonna look at all the stats folks, however many seconds ago or minutes ago that was, it just finally loaded Which I guess is maybe forgivable because we're like close to a million downloads, so they're they're doing a lot of
我没想到，这很难想到。我不确定我是否能猜到。我的意思是，不可能有那么多包含 ETH 的国家，对吧？统计数据已经加载完毕。当我几秒钟或几分钟前说我要查看所有统计数据时，它终于加载了。我想这也许是可以原谅的，因为我们快有一百万次下载了，所以他们正在做很多
partitioning stuff, so if I go see all countries now and 18,000 downloads from the continent of Africa Ethiopia has had 271 downloads so at some point someone probably not just one person because we don't have 271 downloads. So at some point, someone, probably not just one person, because we don't have 271 episodes, at least two people have listened from Ethiopia. They just, I don't know, you either offended them. I imagine it would have been you that offended them, not me. Or they just have an irregular listening pattern and they might be listening before August.
分区处理，所以如果我现在查看所有国家，非洲大陆有 18,000 次下载，埃塞俄比亚有 271 次下载，所以某个时候，可能不仅仅是一个人，因为我们没有 271 次下载。所以某个时候，某个人，可能不仅仅是一个人，因为我们没有 271 期节目，至少有两个人是从埃塞俄比亚收听的。他们只是，我不知道，要么是你冒犯了他们。我想应该是你冒犯了他们，而不是我。或者他们只是有不规律的收听习惯，他们可能会在八月之前收听。
So if you do happen to be one of the handful of folks that listens in Ethiopia and you're interested in helping Bryce out. Yeah, reach out to me. Hit him up. You can reach me on email. You can reach me on the X. You can reach me on LinkedIn. Lots of places. So where are you gonna be? Oh, and I should say, last place I'm gonna be, but I'm probably not gonna do a meetup because it's gonna be purely vacation, but we're gonna be in Tokyo and then Vietnam, Cambodia, and Thailand for the holidays next year.
所以如果你恰好是埃塞俄比亚为数不多的听众之一，并且你有兴趣帮助 Bryce。是的，联系我。找他。你可以通过电子邮件联系我。你可以在 X 上联系我。你可以在 LinkedIn 上联系我。很多地方都可以。那你会在哪里？哦，我应该说，我最后要去的地方，但我可能不会在那里组织聚会，因为那纯粹是度假，但明年假期期间我们会去东京，然后去越南、柬埔寨和泰国。
Ooh, that's gonna be nice. So I suppose I would say that if someone really, really, really wanted us to speak at an event in Thailand or Vietnam or even Tokyo around the holidays, you could reach out and I could try to clear it with the girlfriend. Yeah. So what about you? What's your travel going to look like for this year? Honestly, I haven't made any you ping me about this the other day.
哦，那会很棒。所以我认为，如果有人真的、真的、真的希望我们在假期期间在泰国、越南甚至东京的某个活动上演讲，你可以联系我，我会试着和女朋友商量一下。是的。那你呢？你今年的旅行计划是什么样的？老实说，我还没做任何，你前几天还问我这个。
I have a document at Google Doc. I love Google Docs folks. Another tangent. I love applications. Whether that is a website or a phone. I guess it has to be a website because it's desktop based. If you have emoji colon completion, like colon start typing the name of the emoji. I love it.
我有一个 Google 文档。我爱 Google 文档，伙计们。另一个题外话。我喜欢应用程序。无论是网站还是手机。我想它必须是网站，因为它是基于桌面的。如果你有表情符号冒号补全，就像冒号开始输入表情符号的名字。我喜欢它。
I love it, folks. I love it. And I technically do have like an emoji program installed where I can bring up something, but just being able in place to do that and Google Docs has that now. Colon you start typing. It's fantastic. It also has if you copy and paste YouTube links you can tab complete to get like a little
我喜欢它，伙计们。我喜欢它。而且我技术上确实安装了一个表情符号程序，我可以调出一些东西，但能够直接在原地做到这一点，Google 文档现在有了。冒号，你开始输入。太棒了。如果你复制并粘贴 YouTube 链接，它还可以通过 Tab 键补全来获得一个小
kind of YouTube hyperlink preview with a little YouTube thing. I love Google Docs. I bring this up because I have one, two, three, four, five, six spreadsheets in my bookmark bar. We'll go through them. They are named ADSP, Arraycast, Wedding, Wait, POW, which is not Prisoners of War. It is Portfolio of Words. I migrated my spreadsheet to a Google Sheet and then Finance. And then we have four documents that are just Google Docs. Goals, RTW, Cal, which is short for calories, and diet. And RTW is the one we're gonna talk about. It is running the world.
类似 YouTube 超链接预览的东西，带有一个小的 YouTube 图标。我爱 Google 文档。我提到这个是因为我的书签栏里有 1、2、3、4、5、6 个电子表格。我们来看看。它们被命名为 ADSP、Arraycast、Wedding、Wait、POW，不是战俘，是词汇组合。我把我的电子表格迁移到了 Google 表格，然后是财务。然后我们有四个文档只是 Google 文档。目标、RTW、Cal（卡路里的缩写）和饮食。RTW 是我们要谈论的那个。它是“跑遍世界”。
Oh, I thought so. Okay, yeah. Which is, it has become, it started out as just places that I was traveling to that was either gonna be a new country or a place that I was traveling to that was either gonna be a new country Or a place that I hadn't run a street in or a place. I might be for like a week or so Because I get very excited there's like I still remember when I went to the Northwest Territories last year with Shima and
哦，我以为是。好的，是的。也就是，它已经变成了，最初只是我旅行去的地方，要么是一个新的国家，要么是我旅行去的地方，要么是一个新的国家，或者是一个我还没跑过街道的地方，或者是一个我可能会待上一周左右的地方。因为我感到非常兴奋，我还记得去年我和 Shima 去西北地区的时候，
I was like man. We're there for like eight days I'm probably gonna be able to hammer out this whole city and I was able to run 97% of it in like eight days of running like 20k a day and also too there was a city called Nadillo probably pronouncing that wrong N-D-I-L-O with a couple accents on the the vowels or something and it was like 12 streets so my first run I went a 20k run and I hammered out an entire municipality with 12 streets it was I was a few things in life get me as excited as completing streets in like a single or a city in a single run
我当时想，伙计。我们在那里待了大约八天，我可能能够跑完整个城市，我确实在八天内跑了 97%，每天跑 20 公里。而且还有一个叫 Nadillo 的城市，我可能发音错了，N-D-I-L-O，元音上带了几个重音符号什么的，它只有 12 条街道，所以我的第一次跑步我跑了 20 公里，我跑完了一个拥有 12 条街道的整个城市，这真是，生活中很少有事情能像在一次跑步中跑完一个城市那样让我兴奋。
anyways but I have started to add conferences and just basically any travel whether it's running related or not and currently these are the conferences that I have added the dates no indication that I'm going to these it's just like maybe I would want to go. And some of these, the CFPs are already closed. The first one is PyCon in May of 2025. I think a couple different people told me about the CFP closing back in December.
总之，但我已经开始添加会议，基本上任何旅行，无论是否与跑步有关，目前这些是我添加的会议日期，没有迹象表明我一定会去这些地方，只是说也许我想去。其中一些，征稿启事（CFP）已经截止了。第一个是 2025 年 5 月的 PyCon。我想有几个人告诉我 CFP 在十二月就截止了。
I honestly have been rejected the last two years from PyCon and I couldn't really think of anything. I mean, ironically, now I definitely have something to talk about because you and Jake were telling me that I should be looking at SciPy or PyCon. What I've heard about PyCon is that PyCon wants to hear, like they want to see talks on like established things is what I've heard, is like that they want talks on like established like existing things and that it can be hard to get a talk on like something like new and novel accepted in it at PyCon. That PyCon's less like CppCon where like you can talk about some new bold thing where PyCon wants to be more a little bit more like Educational and like
老实说，过去两年我都被 PyCon 拒绝了，我实在想不出什么。我的意思是，讽刺的是，现在我确实有东西可以谈了，因为你和 Jake 告诉我我应该关注 SciPy 或 PyCon。关于 PyCon 我听说的是，PyCon 想听，他们想看到关于已建立事物的演讲，这是我听到的，他们想要关于已建立的、现有的事物的演讲，而且在 PyCon 上获得关于新颖事物的演讲批准可能很难。PyCon 不太像 CppCon，你可以谈论一些大胆的新事物，而 PyCon 希望更具教育意义，
Oriented for the masses and for beginners and so because of that they really focus on like things that are established that are existing best Practice I don't even know if my PyCon talks gonna get accepted. Yeah, that's fair enough It's more though that, yeah, I just, at the time I went to sit down right before the deadline to like, I had written out a couple talks that I was interested in giving in 2025, and none of them were like, I thought PyCon suitable. Most of them were like functional programming composition,
面向大众和初学者，所以正因为如此，他们真的专注于已建立的、现有的最佳实践。我甚至不知道我的 PyCon 演讲是否会被接受。是的，这很公平。不过更多的是，是的，我只是，在截止日期前我坐下来的时候，我写了几个我想在 2025 年做的演讲，没有一个我觉得适合 PyCon。大多数是关于函数式编程组合，
you know, array programming-esque. And so it didn't seem like a good fit. Anyways, we'll rattle through the, and so I honestly don't have plans on, like, obviously not going to PyCon because I didn't submit a talk. The next one I have is Lambda days in the middle of June. I don't think I'll be going to this one,
你知道，数组编程风格的。所以看起来不太合适。总之，我们会快速过一遍，所以我老实说没有计划，显然不会去 PyCon，因为我没有提交演讲。下一个是六月中旬的 Lambda Days。我不认为我会去参加这个，
but there's a chance that I might end up being in Europe in June, in which case, yeah, I might pop over. Although I think the CFP closes or is closing soon. By the time you're listening to this it might be closed then PLDI 2025 I would only go talk talk I would only go to that conference if I got a paper accepted to the array workshop
但有可能我六月份会在欧洲，如果是那样的话，是的，我可能会顺便去一下。虽然我认为 CFP 已经截止或即将截止。当你听到这个的时候，它可能已经截止了。PLDI 2025，我只有在我的论文被数组研讨会接受的情况下才会去那个会议。
Which I may or may not submit one Then there's the two NDC talks in September Copenhagen and tech town Which is in Kongsberg which got mentioned either in this episode or the one before. I don't think yeah like I said I don't really have plans to go to those that's gonna be right before not right before a couple months before my wedding. Then Dialogue the APL company might be doing some kind of meetup or mini conference in the states I've heard of. That's nothing is announced there.
我可能会也可能不会提交一篇。然后是九月份的两个 NDC 会议，哥本哈根和 Tech Town，在 Kongsberg，这在本期或上一期提到过。我不认为，是的，就像我说的，我真的没有计划去那些地方，那将是在我婚礼前，不是紧接着，而是几个月前。然后是 Dialogue，APL 公司可能在美国做某种聚会或小型会议，我听说过。目前还没有宣布任何消息。
Minnowbrook which is a APL conference I went to in the past. That is something I'd love to go to but once again information on that isn't out yet. And then Lambda World is at the end of October. Probably not gonna go to that because it's like a week or two before my wedding. Anyway, so I have a lot of stuff on my radar, but I don't actually have official plans to go to any of this If oh, yeah, and I didn't mention it I don't know why it's actually not on this list the one conference I do know that I will definitely be going to is CBP North
Minnowbrook，这是一个我过去参加过的 APL 会议。那是我很想去的地方，但同样，关于它的信息还没有出来。然后 Lambda World 在十月底。可能不会去那个，因为它离我的婚礼只有一两周。总之，我的雷达上有很多东西，但我实际上没有去任何这些地方的官方计划。哦，是的，我没提到，我不知道为什么它实际上不在这个列表上，我知道我一定会去的唯一一个会议是 CPP North。
Because I do not have to travel to go to CP CPP North and the dates for that if Yes, I actually have it right here. It's a July 20th to 23rd July 20th it is now going in the the Google Doc. I just shared with you my my Calendar of things Or my my my sheet with with trips. Oh, it's via email. I assume or something like that I shared it with oh did I share with you? I think I did Yeah, yeah, yeah anyways all this to say it's a
因为我不必为了去 CPP North 而旅行，如果日期是，是的，我实际上就在这里。是 7 月 20 日到 23 日，7 月 20 日，现在它要进入 Google 文档了。我刚刚和你分享了我的旅行日历，或者我的旅行表格。哦，是通过电子邮件，我假设或者类似的东西，我分享给了，哦，我分享给你了吗？我想我分享了。是的，是的，是的，总之所有这些都是说，
Usually I'll tell myself. Oh, it'll be a light conference year, but then at some point I get really excited about some topic and then But that's the thing is like there's conferences that it's so early in the year that like they haven't opened their CFP. I gotta go through sometime today and write down when everybody opens up their their CFPs but you know I've been looking at some of the other NDC conferences and also there's this series of conferences called aox that look kind of interesting. And then there's this, so I was looking at my, you introduced me to this app for tracking
通常我会告诉自己，哦，这将是轻松的会议年，但后来在某个时候，我对某个话题感到非常兴奋，然后，但重点是，有些会议在年初太早了，以至于他们还没有开放 CFP。我今天得找时间把每个人开放 CFP 的时间写下来，但你知道，我一直在看其他一些 NDC 会议，还有一系列叫 aox 的会议看起来也很有趣。然后还有这个，所以我正在看我的，你向我介绍了这个用于跟踪
what countries you've been to. And then of course I realized that you'd been to more countries than me and then immediately got jealous and was like, all right, we gotta fix that. I told Ramon, like, you know, we're going to Vietnam. Like, we may as well just stop into Cambodia just for like a day or two just so I can cross it off the list. You shouldn't be competing with me. Shima's been to like 50 or 60 countries.
你去过哪些国家的应用程序。然后我当然意识到你去过的国家比我多，然后立刻嫉妒了，心想，好吧，我们得解决这个问题。我告诉 Ramon，你知道，我们要去越南。我们不如顺便去柬埔寨待上一两天，这样我就可以把它从名单上划掉了。你不应该和我竞争。Shima 去过 50 或 60 个国家。
I know. Do you know how many you've been to? I think it's like 32. Let me check. I think it's like 32. Let me check. I ran into, I was at my middle school, my middle school starting an alumni association and one of my friends from my class in middle school, he was there on the founding call and we chatted a little bit and he's doing some really cool stuff. His name is Jacob Komar and he mentioned that he's been to like 59 countries and travels like you know like 80 or 90 percent of the year because he actually has a production company for like streamers and stuff like that and I was like oh wow like 50 countries like I gotta I gotta up my game but I'll show you I don't know if this how am I got to up my game, but I'll show you. I don't know how well this is going to show up on the screen. I'm going to send you a screenshot, but out of Europe, the only places that I've not been to in Europe that we can currently go to is a couple of the Baltic countries, so no Latvia, Lithuania, Estonia, were going to Portugal for Thanksgiving, but then Denmark, haven't been to Denmark, been to every other
我知道。你知道你去过多少个吗？我想是 32 个左右。让我查一下。我想是 32 个左右。让我查一下。我遇到了，我在我的中学，我的中学正在成立校友会，我中学班里的一个朋友，他在创始电话会议上，我们聊了一会儿，他正在做一些非常酷的事情。他的名字叫 Jacob Komar，他提到他去过 59 个国家，一年里有 80% 或 90% 的时间都在旅行，因为他实际上有一家为流媒体等制作内容的制作公司，我当时想，哦哇，50 个国家，我得，我得提升我的水平，但我会给你看，我不知道这，我怎么提升我的水平，但我会给你看。我不知道这在屏幕上显示效果如何。我会给你发一张截图，但在欧洲之外，我在欧洲唯一没去过但我们目前可以去的地方是几个波罗的海国家，所以没有拉脱维亚、立陶宛、爱沙尼亚，我们要去葡萄牙过感恩节，但丹麦，还没去过丹麦，去过其他所有
Scandinavian country, but not Denmark. And so I want to get Denmark. So I'm looking for a Denmark conference or something. There's this Copenhagen Developers Festival that I heard about somewhere. It looks pretty cool. I think unfortunately, the dates are going to be when we're going to be in Africa this year. But I don't know, maybe I'll try to find some other conference out there. But anyways, we should do the 2025 predictions, right?
斯堪的纳维亚国家，但没去过丹麦。所以我想要去丹麦。所以我正在寻找丹麦的会议或类似的东西。我从某处听说过这个哥本哈根开发者节。看起来很酷。我想不幸的是，日期正好是我们今年在非洲的时候。但我不知道，也许我会试着在外面找其他会议。但总之，我们应该做 2025 年的预测，对吧？
Oh yeah, we've got only, well, it's all right, we've got a few minutes, so yes, let's do a couple 2025 predictions. Hot takes, top three, program-related, non-programming-related general? Go. Oh, boy. Well, I would say that I definitely think you and I are going to be talking a lot less about C++ and a lot more about other languages over the course of this year. And I feel like there's a general, it's a little bit of a shift at least for like this sort of code that we interact with, which is like more compute heavy code like data science, you know, HPC stuff like that. I see more and more of that moving to like DSLs into Python and DSLs built in Python. And I think that's a trend that's going to continue. People are still going to write libraries
哦是的，我们只有，好吧，没关系，我们还有几分钟，所以是的，让我们做几个 2025 年的预测。热门观点，前三名，编程相关的，非编程相关的，一般的？开始。哦，天哪。好吧，我会说我绝对认为你和我今年会少谈很多 C++，而会更多地谈论其他语言。我觉得有一个普遍的，至少对于我们交互的这类代码来说，有一个转变，那就是更多计算密集型的代码，比如数据科学、HPC 之类的。我看到越来越多的代码转向 DSL，转向 Python 和用 Python 构建的 DSL。我认为这是一个将持续下去的趋势。人们仍然会写库
and lower level code, at least to some degree, in languages like C++, but I think we're going to see more and more applications moving towards other languages into DSLs and higher level languages. I mean that's a trend that's been going on for a long while but I think in particular for us and for the spaces that we're in, which is really compute, we're going to see a lot more of that. that. I suspect that we'll talk more about AI and machine learning. A bold prediction, a bold prediction there. What company do you work for again? I don't know whether we're going to see orders of magnitude
和底层代码，至少在某种程度上，使用像 C++ 这样的语言，但我认为我们会看到越来越多的应用程序转向其他语言，转向 DSL 和更高级的语言。我的意思是，这是一个已经持续了很长时间的趋势，但我认为特别是对我们和我们所处的领域，也就是计算领域，我们会看到更多这种情况。我怀疑我们会更多地谈论人工智能和机器学习。一个大胆的预测，一个大胆的预测。你又是在哪家公司工作来着？我不知道我们是否会看到数量级的
advances, though. I feel like maybe it's like with the self-driving cars, where we saw a lot of advances really quickly, but then there's that last 10% that's sort of hard to reach. So I don't know. Maybe we'll be surprised. But is it going to be a rapid acceleration, or is it going to be a little bit slower from here on out?
进步。虽然我觉得这可能就像自动驾驶汽车一样，我们很快看到了很多进步，但最后那 10% 很难达到。所以我不知道。也许我们会感到惊讶。但这会是快速加速，还是从现在开始会慢一点？
Other things that we might talk about, I think we will probably talk more about Rust within the next year. And I think that we will talk more on this podcast about programming language design for a variety of reasons that I don't think we can share with the listeners yet. But I think we'll talk more about programming language design. And yeah, I guess C++ 26 will come out. I suspect that C++ 26 will be a pretty big release.
我们可能会谈论的其他事情，我想我们明年可能会更多地谈论 Rust。而且我认为我们在这个播客上会更多地谈论编程语言设计，原因有很多，我想我们还不能和听众分享。但我认为我们会更多地谈论编程语言设计。是的，我想 C++ 26 会出来。我怀疑 C++ 26 会是一个相当大的版本。
I think we'll get reflection. I think we'll probably get a little bit more of reflection than we think. I think we're going to get, obviously, we're going to get senders, which has already been in for a while. I think contracts will happen. I think we'll end up doing some set of things in the name of safety.
我想我们会得到反射。我想我们可能会得到比我们想象中更多的反射。我想我们会得到，显然，我们会得到 senders，它已经存在一段时间了。我想契约（contracts）会实现。我想我们最终会以安全的名义做一些事情。
Maybe we'll get some form of profiles. But I think when we step back in three to six months, C++26 is going to look like a pretty big release. And people are going to be pretty excited about it and about the scale of what we're looking at. the scale of what we're looking at. But I don't think that's going to change this trend of people, especially people who are in C++
也许我们会得到某种形式的配置文件（profiles）。但我认为当我们三到六个月后回顾时，C++ 26 看起来会是一个相当大的版本。人们会对此以及我们所关注的规模感到非常兴奋。我们所关注的规模。但我认为这不会改变人们的趋势，特别是那些处于 C++
leadership positions starting to think about C++ more and more of a legacy language. So I think despite the successes of C++ 26, that's going to continue to be the perspective. And I think that we will see fewer, we will see successor languages like things that are attempting to be C++ 2.0. I think we're going to see more and more of those disappear over the next year because we've talked before about how it's really hard for a new language to come in and disrupt the incumbent. I think there's only really space for one or two to do that.
领导地位的人开始把 C++ 越来越多地视为一种遗留语言。所以我认为尽管 C++ 26 取得了成功，但这仍将是人们的观点。而且我认为我们会看到更少的，我们会看到继任语言，比如那些试图成为 C++ 2.0 的东西。我认为明年我们会看到越来越多的这类语言消失，因为我们之前谈过，新语言很难进入并颠覆现有者。我认为只有一两个空间可以做到这一点。
I think Rust has gotten enough momentum behind it that Rust is going to be the successor language, especially with the drive for safety and the fears about regulation and regulatory concerns. I think that Rust is just going to be the thing that we're going to all turn towards. So I think there's going to be a consolidation in the systems programming world around Rust as the future.
我认为 Rust 已经有了足够的动力，Rust 将成为继任语言，特别是在对安全性的推动以及对监管和监管担忧的情况下。我认为 Rust 将成为我们所有人都会转向的东西。所以我认为系统编程世界将围绕 Rust 作为未来进行整合。
And I think some of these projects to build C++ successors are going to maybe start to close up shop. What about you? What are your predictions? I mean, those are all great predictions. I mean, the AI, LLM, or machine learning, I guess, is what you said. Is that really a prediction?
而且我认为其中一些构建 C++ 继任者的项目可能会开始关门。你呢？你的预测是什么？我的意思是，这些都是很棒的预测。我的意思是，人工智能、LLM 或机器学习，我想这就是你说的。那真的是预测吗？
I think the sky could be blue some of the days. But I put out some caution. I said that I don't know that we're going to see. I think we'll see more adoption of the large language model technology that exists today. I don't know that we're gonna see Radical breakthroughs in new technology, but there's just a lot of room to just adopt what currently exists Yeah, I will counter that prediction with
我想天空在某些日子里可能是蓝色的。但我提出了一些谨慎。我说我不知道我们是否会看到。我想我们会看到更多对当今存在的大语言模型技术的采用。我不知道我们是否会看到新技术上的激进突破，但采用目前存在的东西还有很大的空间。是的，我会用
the opposite I think I don't necessarily know if there's gonna be like, you know, a GPT, you know 2.5 to 3 and 4 like those step functions. I think there's gonna be some improvements, but I think it's just gonna be adopted more and my prediction, my actual prediction coming out of this topic is that the rise of the 100x developer will occur. You know, some people say 10x dev is not really a thing. I definitely know a handful, if not more, of developers that I've met across the three companies I've worked for during my, we'll call it generously a short career.
相反的观点来反驳那个预测。我不一定知道是否会有，你知道，GPT，你知道 2.5 到 3 和 4 那样的阶跃函数。我认为会有一些改进，但我认为它只是会被更多地采用，而我的预测，我从这个话题中得出的实际预测是，100 倍开发者的崛起将会发生。你知道，有些人说 10 倍开发者不是真的。我绝对认识几个，如果不是更多的话，我在我工作过的三家公司里遇到的开发者，在我们称之为慷慨的短暂职业生涯中。
And they are, I would say like on average 10x better, if not more. They are people that I refer to as like wizards that are just very productive, very good. And I think that those people are now going to be another order of magnitude better than like your average dev because what you are able to do and I think that it enables too like your 1x dev to become a 10x dev like the the tool that profiling tool in like an hour or two because of code completion and like LLMs and It is just it is the power of being able to like, you know that scene in inception when
他们是，我会说平均比普通开发者好 10 倍，如果不是更多的话。他们是我称之为巫师的人，他们非常高效，非常出色。而且我认为这些人现在将比你的普通开发者好一个数量级，因为你能够做到的事情，而且我认为它也使你的 1 倍开发者能够成为 10 倍开发者，就像那个分析工具，在一两个小时内，因为代码补全和 LLM，它就是能够像，你知道《盗梦空间》里的那个场景，当
What's what's the actors name? They're the actor from Juno, but they construct the dreams. They're the dream constructor. And her character goes in with Leonardo DiCaprio and he's explaining, oh yeah, you can change things. You're the architect. And then she realizes that like, oh, I can do anything. And she starts Flipping the world upside down and folding it in on
那个演员的名字是什么？他们是来自《朱诺》的演员，但他们构建梦境。他们是梦境构建者。她的角色和莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥一起进去，他解释说，哦是的，你可以改变事物。你是建筑师。然后她意识到，哦，我可以做任何事。她开始把世界翻转过来并折叠起来
Itself you remember that scene. Yeah, that's what it feels like to have an LLM at your fingertips anyway, so I think the the rise of the 100x developer and I mean you There's one person that and I know you know who I have in mind, who I know exactly. I wonder whether this person. They're going to become a 1000x death. Yeah, but I wonder whether he uses them today. I'm going to ask. I'm going to ask.
你自己还记得那个场景吗？是的，这就是拥有 LLM 在指尖的感觉。总之，所以我认为 100 倍开发者的崛起，我的意思是，你，有一个人，我知道你心里想的是谁，我完全知道。我不知道这个人是否今天在使用它们。我要问问。我要问问。
I said they to, what's the word, obfuscate the gender, now you've given you've given the listener a hint. By the time this is published it's all gonna be out there. I still you know and we're gonna respect his privacy and not say anything here, although we should have them on at some point but yeah. Yeah so I just think that yeah for and I've foo- and I've heard too, I was listening to an interview with, I don't know his name, can't remember it, but he is the individual that was previously, I think, the CEO of HashiCorp and is now the main developer of the Ghosty Terminal emulator, which has had a lot of hype recently, it's being written in Zig. And he basically says that like whenever the network networks down, internet's down, he just
我说“他们”来，怎么说，混淆性别，现在你已经给听众一个提示了。当这期节目发布时，一切都会公开的。我仍然，你知道，我们会尊重他的隐私，在这里什么都不说，尽管我们应该在某个时候邀请他们来，但是的。是的，所以我只是认为，是的，对于，而且我也听说，我正在听一个采访，我不记得他的名字了，但他就是之前，我想，是 HashiCorp 的 CEO，现在是 Ghosty 终端模拟器的主要开发者，最近有很多炒作，它是用 Zig 编写的。他基本上说，每当网络断了，互联网断了，他就
like stops working because he's just like it's not worth his time if he doesn't have access to these like code completion tools because he's just like, well, I guess I'm done for the day. Anyways, that's my prediction. 100x devs, your ability to build things is just, it's just, it feels so cool. Like I said, insert a clip of the folding the city in on itself. My question is, what happens when you start messing with the physics of it all? I'm not sure if I'm going to die here. Something isn't it? Yes it is.
停止工作，因为他只是觉得如果他没有使用这些代码补全工具的权限，那就不值得他花时间，因为他只是觉得，好吧，我想我今天干完了。总之，这就是我的预测。100 倍开发者，你构建事物的能力，它只是，它只是，感觉太酷了。就像我说的，插入一段把城市折叠起来的片段。我的问题是，当你开始摆弄这一切的物理原理时会发生什么？我不确定我是否会死在这里。有什么东西不是吗？是的，它是。
Other predictions, what some hot takes. I mean, Rust, I've predicted the last two or three years on my YouTube channel that Rust would become a top 10 language according to my PLRank.com site. It has not happened and I've realized that's because the gap in the average ranking, it has a lot to close. Right now Go is in the tenth spot with an average language ranking across Stack Overflow, Octoverse, Redbunk, and Languish of 10.25. Rust is sitting at number 11 with an average ranking of 13.33. So that's more than three average ranking spots. So it would really need to go up on one or two of these ranking sites. So do I think Rust is going to break into the top 10?
其他预测，一些热门观点。我的意思是，Rust，我在我的 YouTube 频道上预测了过去两三年，Rust 将根据我的 PLRank.com 网站成为前 10 名语言。这并没有发生，我意识到这是因为平均排名的差距，它还有很多要弥补的。目前 Go 在第十位，在 Stack Overflow、Octoverse、Redbunk 和 Languish 的平均语言排名为 10.25。Rust 排在第 11 位，平均排名为 13.33。所以那是超过三个平均排名位置。所以它真的需要在这些排名网站中的一个或两个上上升。那么你认为 Rust 会进入前 10 名吗？
I don't think so. I actually don't think so for the first time in like two or three years. You'd think that we'd be closer than ever now, but not really. I don't know. I want to make a programming language prediction. What would be a hot take? Let's take a look at the functional languages. Gleam jumped into the top 20 and went from 17th to 13th. Maybe we'll predict that Gleam breaks into the top 10. And what is my third prediction? My third prediction alongside the 100x developer, unfortunately. I mean this might be a bit bit controversial because I think Zuckerberg a lot of controversial tech people at the moment. Oh, yeah, maybe maybe we can talk about that too for a couple of seconds. I don't know. I'll chat about that later. Keep that off air. But you know, Zuckerberg said that he was going to replace a bunch of his employees with LLMs. I think that
我不这么认为。事实上，这是两三年以来我第一次不这么认为。你可能会觉得我们现在应该比以往任何时候都更亲近，但事实并非如此。我不知道。我想对编程语言做一个预测。什么会是热门话题？让我们看看函数式语言。Gleam 冲进了前 20 名，从第 17 位上升到了第 13 位。也许我们可以预测 Gleam 会进入前 10 名。我的第三个预测是什么？不幸的是，我的第三个预测与“百倍开发者”有关。我的意思是，这可能会引起一些争议，因为我认为扎克伯格目前有很多有争议的科技界人士。哦，是的，也许我们可以花几秒钟谈谈这个。我不知道。我稍后再聊这个。别在节目里说。但你知道，扎克伯格说他要用大语言模型（LLM）取代他的一大批员工。我认为
that that is not false. I think that is he is being truthful when he says that. And that is not false. I think that he is being truthful when he says that. And that is going to be a trend across companies that employ software developers, is that there is going to be less opportunities, probably layoffs. And the 10x devs that become 100x devs are going to replace teams of people and for better or for worse that
这并非虚言。我认为当他说这话时，他是真诚的。这并非虚言。我认为当他说这话时，他是真诚的。这将成为雇佣软件开发人员的公司的趋势，即机会会减少，可能会出现裁员。而那些成为“百倍开发者”的“十倍开发者”将取代整个团队，无论好坏，这
She she was eating a banana she just wandered over because she's listening to what I'm saying it's not in her head going Would you like to say something we're making predictions about 2023 you got any Would you like to say something? We're making predictions about 2023. You got any predictions? 2025 not 2023. 2025, my bad. I don't know what happened there for a moment. She's got a banana.
她……她刚才在吃香蕉，她只是溜达过来，因为她在听我说话，她脑子里并没有在想“你想说点什么吗？”我们正在对 2023 年做出预测，你有什么……你想说点什么吗？我们正在对 2023 年做出预测。你有什么预测吗？是 2025 年，不是 2023 年。2025 年，我的错。我不知道刚才发生了什么。她手里拿着香蕉。
She's eaten the banana. And are we still buying? This is actually I said we were going to keep this off air. Are we still going to buy a Tesla? I am 34 turning 35 have never owned a car in my life, vowed that I would buy an EV, stands for electric vehicle, for those that aren't familiar with the acronym, and I feel bad, given, I know it's been a month, but if you've forgotten what's happened right after the inauguration,
她吃完了香蕉。我们还要买吗？其实我说过我们要把这个话题留在节目外讨论。我们还要买特斯拉吗？我 34 岁，快 35 岁了，这辈子从没买过车，我发誓要买一辆电动汽车（EV，对于不熟悉这个缩写的人来说，它是电动汽车的缩写），我感到很内疚，我知道已经过去一个月了，但如果你忘了就职典礼后发生了什么，
Elon's in a little bit of hot water, whether or not you think he was- You're not putting this on air, right? What? You're not airing it. Yeah, this is- we're recording the podcast. Shima just said you're not putting this on air, right? Yeah, we're recording the podcast. Shima just said you're not putting this on the air, are you? Anyway, it's a little bit controversial, but we still want to buy the Tesla
埃隆陷入了一点麻烦，不管你是否认为他……你不会把这段播出去吧？什么？你不会播出的。是的，这是……我们在录制播客。希玛刚才说你不会把它播出去，对吧？是的，我们在录制播客。希玛刚才说你不会把它播出去，对吧？总之，这有点争议，但我们还是想买特斯拉，
because Shima's sister and brother-in-law both have Teslas and the FSD full self-driving, folks. 13.0. It is phenomenal. It makes me feel like a bad driver. It makes me feel like every person I'm in a car with when I'm in an Uber is a bad driver.
因为希玛的姐姐和姐夫都有特斯拉，而且还有 FSD 全自动驾驶，伙计们。13.0 版本。太惊人了。它让我觉得自己是个糟糕的司机。它让我觉得每当我坐优步时，车上的每个人都是糟糕的司机。
It's so good. And I feel like we need to divorce the art from the artists so that I can own a Tesla guilt-free. Bryce has things to say. Well, I was just gonna say, we get a lot of rental cars. And so I have some opinions on cars because we just get to experience a lot of different types of cars.
它太棒了。我觉得我们需要将艺术与艺术家分开，这样我才能毫无负罪感地拥有一辆特斯拉。布莱斯有话要说。嗯，我只是想说，我们经常租车。所以我对汽车有一些看法，因为我们确实体验过很多不同类型的车。
About a year ago, we had a rental somewhere and the only thing they had available for us was electric vehicles. They gave us one of the Kia EV6s, their crossover SUV thing. the lady at the rental car agency, she was like, oh, I think you're really going to like it. Like, I prefer these over the Teslas. And we drove it, and we really loved it. I don't know that the self-driving, like it has self-driving features that are probably
大约一年前，我们在某个地方租了一辆车，他们唯一能提供给我们的是电动汽车。他们给了我们一辆起亚 EV6，就是那种跨界 SUV。租车公司的女士说，哦，我想你会非常喜欢它的。她说，比起特斯拉，我更喜欢这些。我们开了之后，真的很喜欢。我不知道它的自动驾驶功能，它确实有自动驾驶功能，可能
not as advanced as Teslas. But as a car, I think it's a better car. If you want the Tesla just for the self-driving features, yeah, they're probably gonna be the boldest and the first to market. But if you want like a better car, like I think the Kia EDs are really, really strong. A couple problems with everything you just said.
不如特斯拉先进。但作为一辆车，我认为它是一辆更好的车。如果你只想要特斯拉的自动驾驶功能，是的，他们可能是最大胆、最先进入市场的。但如果你想要一辆更好的车，我认为起亚的电动车真的非常非常强。你刚才说的所有内容都有几个问题。
First of all, you said when we drove it, that's your number one problem right there. Second of all, you said first to market, it's already your number one problem right there. Second of all, you said first to market. It's already here. Thirteen point oh, it's already here, folks. Why do you need a car? We're going to be probably moving out of the city. Well, I don't. Well, yes, probably.
首先，你说“当我们开它的时候”，这就是你的第一个问题。其次，你说“最先进入市场”，这就是你的第一个问题。其次，你说“最先进入市场”。它已经在这里了。13.0 版本，它已经在这里了，伙计们。你为什么需要一辆车？我们可能要搬出城市了。嗯，我不……嗯，是的，可能吧。
We're probably we're going to try and you know, what do you call it? Like move to the next level of our life. We're living in as we like to call it, a shoebox. Yeah. And we need more space. And I've lived my life long enough. And also too, we tend to visit family more often now, which is irritating to do via transit
我们可能……我们要尝试，你知道，怎么说呢？比如进入我们人生的下一个阶段。我们住在一个我们称之为“鞋盒”的地方。是的。我们需要更多的空间。我这辈子活得够久了。而且，我们现在也更频繁地去看望家人，通过公共交通去那里很烦人，
if you're going that frequently, because it's like an hour plus away and it's only like a 20 minute drive. I absolve you of your guilt. I absolve you of your guilt. Well that's the thing is I I don't really have guilt I just want to I don't want to be canceled because you know like people are leaving Twitter and it's just like just because I'm keeping my Twitter profile it doesn't mean I support the people that are running it. It's just that I get more engagement on Twitter than I do on any of the other platforms. Like everyone's saying,
如果你去得那么频繁，因为它需要一个多小时，而开车只需要 20 分钟。我免除你的负罪感。我免除你的负罪感。嗯，问题是我并没有真正的负罪感，我只是不想被取消，因为你知道，人们正在离开推特，这就像……仅仅因为我保留了我的推特个人资料，并不意味着我支持运营它的人。只是因为我在推特上获得的互动比在其他任何平台上都多。就像每个人都在说，
oh man, everybody moved to Mastodon, everybody moved to Blue Sky. That's not true. It's not true. I now have been posting on all three platforms, every post that I do. And in general, sometimes on Mastodon, depending on the type of post, I might get a little bit more interaction. But on average, Twitter is still the place where there's the largest community and I knew I just like I understand why people are it makes me feel so good that you said that because I've been I've been thinking more and more lately should I be going and building you know should I be going and doing my social media somewhere else it feels like there's fewer and fewer people on Twitter.
哦天哪，大家都搬到了 Mastodon，大家都搬到了 Blue Sky。那不是真的。那不是真的。我现在在所有三个平台上发布内容，我发布的每一条帖子都是如此。总的来说，有时在 Mastodon 上，根据帖子的类型，我可能会获得更多的互动。但平均而言，推特仍然是拥有最大社区的地方，我知道我只是……我理解为什么人们会……你说那番话让我感觉太好了，因为我最近一直在想，我是否应该去建立……我是否应该去别的地方做我的社交媒体？感觉推特上的人越来越少了。
It makes me feel so good that you're validating my laziness. I will say, folks, it is mostly laziness and exhaustion. If people keep asking me why I'm not on the other platforms, it's because having to take on another social media and messaging platform and having to think about that and having to deal with that is a lot of mental energy for me. And I'm not sure that I want to take that on. If there's any place that I would be likely to post
你认可我的懒惰，这让我感觉太好了。我会说，伙计们，这主要是因为懒惰和疲惫。如果人们一直问我为什么不在其他平台上，那是因为不得不承担另一个社交媒体和消息平台，并且不得不考虑和处理这些事情，对我来说需要消耗大量的脑力。我不确定我是否想承担这些。如果有什么地方我可能会发布
more stuff, it would probably be on LinkedIn, just because that's an existing thing. And I already have some number of people that reach out to me about things on LinkedIn. I'm not sure that I'm ready to go and commit to some new platform. And that's the thing, I would love to get off of Twitter but like while there is a larger community of tech folks and also too like I hear stuff about the toxicity and the policies and in my tech corner of Twitter, which is mostly programming language, C++ and array people, array language people, I have very rarely encountered anything and if I do, I just block the person. And people, I know that, I don't even really understand, I know I think Blue Sky or Macedon, they allow you to block words and stuff.
更多内容，那可能是领英（LinkedIn），因为那是一个现有的东西。而且已经有一些人会在领英上就某些事情联系我。我不确定我是否准备好去致力于某个新平台。这就是问题所在，我很想离开推特，但虽然那里有更大的科技群体，而且我也听说了一些关于毒性和政策的事情，但在我的推特科技圈子里，主要是编程语言、C++ 和数组语言的人，我很少遇到任何问题，如果遇到了，我就直接屏蔽那个人。我知道，我甚至不太理解，我知道我想 Blue Sky 或 Mastodon，它们允许你屏蔽词汇之类的东西。
But I never encounter things, like I'm not saying it doesn't exist, I'm just saying in my little corner of Twitter, it doesn't seem that bad. I have heard that it is not great for a lot of folks, but that hasn't been my experience. Anyways, I just, I feel like we live in an interesting time where, you know, like I said, Elon does some controversial things, and now I am like like I still want FSD FSD is
但我从没遇到过这些事情，我不是说它不存在，我只是说在我的推特小圈子里，情况似乎没那么糟。我听说这对很多人来说并不好，但这并不是我的经历。总之，我只是觉得我们生活在一个有趣的时代，你知道，就像我说的，埃隆做了一些有争议的事情，现在我就像……我仍然想要 FSD，FSD 对我来说
for me like transcends not wanting to support someone because of their Political leanings or whatever but then I also you know, it is a question of you know, do you get an inferior product? When it comes to self-driving, I don't know. It's an interesting question. Stay tuned, folks. Does Connor buy a Tesla? I mean, I think there's nothing wrong with buying a Tesla if you so choose. I appreciate that. I appreciate that. You can be my conscience on this one. Anyways, I'm not sure.
超越了因为某人的政治倾向或其他原因而不愿支持某人的想法，但随后我也……你知道，这是一个问题，你知道，你会得到一个劣质产品吗？当谈到自动驾驶时，我不知道。这是一个有趣的问题。敬请期待，伙计们。康纳会买特斯拉吗？我的意思是，我认为如果你选择买特斯拉，并没有什么错。我很感激。我很感激。在这件事上你可以做我的良心。总之，我不确定。
One could argue that Elon doesn't even really run Tesla or do anything at Tesla because he's too busy going off doing crazy Elon stuff elsewhere. Yeah, that's true. He's become oligarch, whatever, quasi politician, runner of Doge and fire air of people. Yeah. To what extent does he actually run the day-to-day operations of any of his companies is... I have no idea, but I wouldn't be surprised if it's less than people think. Yeah, yeah. I have been thinking... I did download Blue Sky and I do think I've had an account on there since it was invite only, but I've not even set it up or done anything with it. I have noticed that I do feel like I get less engagement on Twitter, but also that's partially
有人可能会说，埃隆甚至没有真正经营特斯拉，或者在特斯拉做任何事情，因为他太忙于在其他地方做疯狂的埃隆式的事情了。是的，那是真的。他已经成为了寡头，无论什么，准政治家，狗狗币的运营者和人们的解雇者。是的。他在多大程度上真正经营着他任何公司的日常运营是……我不知道，但如果比人们想象的要少，我也不会感到惊讶。是的，是的。我一直在想……我确实下载了 Blue Sky，而且我想我从它还是邀请制的时候就有一个账户了，但我甚至没有设置它或做任何事情。我注意到我确实觉得我在推特上的互动减少了，但这部分也是
because a large amount of my tweets now are just about random travel stuff. But also I feel like follower growth is not what it once was on Twitter. Maybe that's just because I don't pay for Twitter, because I don't see a point in paying for Twitter. Again, I don't want to give in. I don't want to give in to the man. I wouldn't say it's a good place, but it's where I am. And on that note. I do think I'll probably post more on LinkedIn because I've been noticing more engagement on LinkedIn
因为我现在的大量推文只是关于随机的旅行琐事。但我也觉得推特上的粉丝增长不如从前了。也许那只是因为我不为推特付费，因为我觉得为推特付费没有意义。再说一次，我不想屈服。我不想向权势屈服。我不会说它是一个好地方，但它是我所在的地方。说到这里。我确实认为我可能会在领英上发布更多内容，因为我注意到领英上的互动更多了
and I've been noticing more people like posting stuff on LinkedIn. And yeah, I may move more content to LinkedIn. You heard it here first, folks. Go follow Bryce on LinkedIn. Yes. Happy New first, folks. Go follow Bryce on LinkedIn. Yes. Happy New Year, folks. Happy New Year, folks.
而且我注意到更多人喜欢在领英上发布内容。是的，我可能会把更多内容转移到领英上。你们在这里先听到了，伙计们。去领英上关注布莱斯吧。是的。新年快乐，伙计们。新年快乐，伙计们。
Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必在您的播客应用程序或 ADSPthepodcast.com 上查看这些节目说明，以获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望您喜欢并祝您有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。收听我们希望您喜欢并祝您有美好的一天。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。